so Donald Trump delivered a completely bizarre
and self-congratulatory and very deranged
graduation speech at West Point over the weekend,
it was riddled with a failed applause lines.
But most notably, at one point, Donald Trump
visibly struggled to raise a glass of water
to his mouth and later struggled to walk down
a ramp, almost having to be helped down the
ramp by a member of the military.
Now I'm going to show you the video and we're
we're going to talk about it.
But this is as much a story about right wing
hypocrisy as it is a story about Donald Trump's
cognitive and physical state.
If Joe Biden did 20 percent of what Trump
did at this speech over the weekend, it would
be a week of Fox News in 08.
And agit trash about Joe Biden has dementia,
with Judge Jeanine bringing in someone whose
cousin's girlfriend once went to medical school
to say that Joe Biden is unfit to lead.
If this was Hillary, it would be Hillary.
Parkinson's times 10 all over again.
And yet here they are pretending like there's
just nothing to see here other than so-called
Trump derangement syndrome.
And by the way, Trump derangement syndrome
is a term that the right has developed to
not have to address criticisms of Donald Trump.
You say something about Trump.
You have Trump derangement syndrome.
It's a way to stop conversation.
So, first of all, at one point during the
speech, Donald Trump goes to drink water,
picks up a glass with his right hand, brings
it about 80 percent of the way to his lips.
His right hand seemingly could go no higher.
He tries moving his mouth down to bring it
down enough to get to the glass.
Couldn't do it.
And eventually uses his left hand to very
strangely pull the glass towards his mouth
and tilt it.
It wasn't clear if the problem was with Trump's
right arm, with his hand eye coordination.
We just have no idea.
But this is not a normal way to drink water.
And it's the second time, at least that we've
seen Donald Trump bizarrely drink water in
this way.
Then the other sort of most notable moment
during the speech was Trump descending the
ramp at the end of the speech, very gingerly,
carefully, like he was about to fall over.
Very strange.
And then he took a sort of hop step at the
bottom of the ramp, which he later described
as jogging down the last 10 feet, which we'll
get to.
You'll also notice that the officer gesturing,
gesturing for Trump to leave the stage and
then walking next to him implies that the
officer was briefed ahead of time.
Stay with Trump going down the ramp.
So, again, we've seen Trump come off of Air
Force One, sometimes with the help of an aide.
We've seen various versions of this.
He just doesn't look stable when he's walking
here.
So is this the most important thing going
on right now?
It's not.
But again, if this was Joe Biden, it would
be a week on right wing media about how this
proves Biden simply cannot be president.
It's also aggravated and becomes more interesting
by Trump immediately lying about it.
Trump tweeting, quote, The ramp that I descended
after my West Point commencement speech was
very long and steep.
Now it's not very steep, had no handrail.
And most importantly, it was very slippery.
It was a sunny day.
It was totally dry.
There's not really any reason why it would
be slippery.
And people who were there said it was not
slippery.
And then Trump saying the last thing I was
going to do is fall for the fake news to have
fun with final 10 feet.
I ran to down to ground level.
That's also a lie.
Trump sort of took a two step hop.
He did not run 10 feet.
So it always attracts more attention and is
worse when Trump starts lying about it.
There also a tweet for everything with Trump.
Trump once criticized Barack Obama for how
he would walk out of Air Force One, tweeting
in 2014 that, quote, Obama should stop running
down the stairs when getting off Air Force
One doesn't look presidential and at some
point he will take a fall.
Never happened.
And by the way, we have video of Barack Obama
on the same ramp that Trump was on.
Obama certainly looking very, very spry.
Nothing to sneeze at there.
So this is all very weird.
And we don't really have an explanation, which
I'll get back to.
The speech was also filled with a ton of really
other weird moments.
Trump at one point attempting to talk about
former President Ulysses S. Grant.
He called him Ulysses S..
A couple of times when we lead, we need you
to carry on the spirit of the great general
Ulysses S. Grant.
That's weird.
Then also struggling with the name Douglas
MacArthur, seemingly saying MacArthur, MacArthur,
really just multiple times.
We need you to be as bold and determined as
the immortal General Douglas MacArthur, who
knew that the American soldier never, ever
quits after leaving the Philippines for Australia
at a low.
Point of the Pacific War in 1942.
MacArthur shamelessly.
I shall return and then maybe the most cringe
worthy moment was Trump's failed applause
line when he mentioned the 240 fifth birthday
of the army and paused and looked around.
It was complete crickets.
And then Trump decided to bring up his own
birthday.
I mean, this is real cringe.
Tomorrow, America will celebrate a very important
anniversary day, 240 fifth birthday of the
United States Army.
Unrelated, going to be my birthday also.
I don't know if that happened by accident.
Did that happen by accident?
Please.
But it's a great day because of that Army
birthday.
So absolutely embarrassing speech.
Now, as far as the medical stuff, Trump couldn't
lift the glass of water with his right arm.
He seemed when he was walking down that ramp
that he was kind of favoring his left side.
If someone wanted to speculate about what's
going on in that, there seems to be a left
right issue here.
You would start thinking about stroke.
Remember that he was taken on short notice
to Walter Reed Hospital.
That time they lied and said, oh, he decided
to get a jump on his 20-20 physical.
That was back in nineteen.
Totally not believable.
You start to imagine because they don't fill
in the details.
Maybe there's something going on here that
could be stroke related.
Now, remember, it's speculative.
We don't know.
And the important thing to remember is if
it were Biden, they would be saying this video
is proof that Biden should be dropping out
of the race.
Really, really crazy stuff.